Rounding is a way to take a number and
say what it's about equal to.
If someone asks you for the time and
you look at your watch and
it says 6:01,
you may just say 6 o'clock.
When you do this,
you are rounding to the nearest hour.
Whenever we round,
we are taking a number and
saying what that number is close to.
Let's take a look at
numbers with a single digit
after the decimal point like 2.6,
3.4, or 1.5.
How do you think we would round these?
For example, let's look at 2.6.
Looking at the number line,
we know that 2.6 is somewhere in-between
2 and 3, but the question is,
is 2.6 to the right or to the left
of the midpoint in-between 2 and 3?
First, let's figure out
what the midpoint is.
What is the midpoint between 2 and 3?
Enter your answer in this box.